isso também se chama maria jácome
o ator diz pessoal aqui quem fala é
andar que seja manteve jamais um vídeo e
eu estou aqui na cozinha mais uma vez
porque eu senti mais iluminado que eu
tenho aqui em casa então não fala de uma
senhora que penso é e como estava a
dizer uma vez nada fazer um vídeo de
fomento é uma coisa sem parecida herança
não fala
sinto que hoje acordei sem que o filme
pronto nunca mais fazer isso aqui eu
decidi que este vídeo vai ser tipo um
blogger não vai ser algo tipo as
aventuras na casa do dark
eu vou andar pela minha casa fazer
coisas de mostrar as coisas não sei o
que vai acontecer agora mas espero ficar
uma coisa interessante pelo menos o que
tenha piada eu vou fazer este vídeo
todos sem corte depois na edição assim
vários cortes mas sair sai e e ainda
está escuro e fazer as coisas dela mas
como ela não muito bem eu posso estar
aqui falar à vontade só se eu falar
assim muito alta daquela mil porque ela
é assim em um mundo ao vivo é fazer uma
comissão em ponto cruz e qual é o plano
do solo plano e obrigar a mais cara do
fred não do ad quem ali no quarto e
voltar a marcar e tentar o resultado ou
alguma coisa assim partida não saiu uma
coisa engraçada visto que hoje já depois
da crips cai um bigode sol é minha mãe
adora este calendário é um calendário
que só fazer mais uma sombra das áreas é
uma coisa agora sim vou tentar algo
estava para lá tem que esconder a caneta
na mão na caneta por não existir provas
contra mim
agora vou estar aqui com esta mas que
não se vocês conseguem ver vamos lá
então e que para mascar e eu já disse
que não tem dúvida vou tentar sair da
casa de banho se levantado muitas
plantas que faltou no meu quarto e não
se assim a fonte uma manta por cima ou
alguma coisa assim possível mas eu vou
tentar achar alguma coisa volta
o ideal era mesmo encontrar um pano
preto ou assim mas não conseguiu
encontrar nada então eu vou te comer
toalha de banho verde
blá blá blá blá
olha eu gosto de fazer essas coisas a
fazer são coisas que gosta de fazer
essas coisas
olha para uma fender tamanho da minha
mãe por isso para não ofender o tabaco
eu era tão linda quando era pequena é a
moldura tem florzinhas eu tenho uma
camisa e as riscas um sorriso sem dentes
quase nenhuns mais um só tempo na parte
de cima uns três ou quatro
é que eu já tinha minha batata que nós
jovens pretos tipos de anthony é meu
isso nem eso estão a questão e seu olho
preto meu seu e do satanás meu penteado
mil euros fizeram penteado a tigela e
ainda me deixaram aqui umas sobras de em
cima do ombro que eu não percebo que é
bom aqui fazer tipo em 1992 e 1996
acho que é isso e barba por falar em
breve vou ter que tirar porque o paulo
rangel um chumbo vocês vão ver uma taxa
que esta técnica você gente tem muito
papel vão fazer isso acho um pneu no
jogo foi que vocês também fazem contou
anamara poemas tempo começa a ler as
coisas as instruções do jeito e do chan
pou eu não sei se isso é interessante
pra vocês
a presidência do sonho daí princípio em
mandar apoia hoje aqui tem álcool é um
bom jogo
adianta que vão tomar nosso cérebro
aplicar todo o cabelo da oferta até a
nuca que a antena nunca foi um que já o
que assim até cá atrás de cabeça na hora
de escolher é o chera mel movimento tem
que ter um ambientador nós quer